you know Ronnie and EG and tanith and
Thea
regier and Selen and thops and Irina
but do you recall the most Jolly NPC of
them all
Alex the Iron Fist Warrior jar had a
very Mighty fist
and those are all the parody lyrics I
came up with so let's start the video
forth with
the Yuletide is upon us so let's take a
look at the jolliest of the lands
between he who stands as a light
throughout the game from Lim grave to
faram Azula shining brighter than the
earth tree filling us with hope and
incandescent reassurance join me now as
we look at the lore and significance of
the Jolly jar Alexander as we will see
the undaunted ubermensch of the lands
between and as we get going just a note
feel free to subscribe if you haven't as
that's many of you I hope you enjoyed
the video and have a great Christmas and
holiday season well wishes for the end
of this year and the beginning of the
new one and with that we move on to
Alexander who seems to me to represent
the direct message of the game from
Miyazaki this jar is undaunted by
difficulty and constantly seeks to
overcome the trials and tribulations of
the lands between those of you who saw
my philosophy of Elden ring video may
remember that I had a section all about
Alexander and how he highlights the
embracement of struggle this makes him
an even greater figure than he at first
seems he is the embodiment of the
philosophy of the whole game a message
which stretches back to at least the
first Souls games now where most players
meet Alexander for the first time we
come across him struggling needing our
help to get out of a hole he is trapped
in because he is a jar Alexander is not
well suited for the world of the lands
between especially not for being a
warrior in it he gets stuck in Holes his
body is prone to cracking even when just
getting out of said holes and his kin
are hunted by poachers in their town of
jarberg nonetheless he persists and
strives to be a fighter and we get to
see his journey as it coincides with
ours whether that be in the radon
festival or at Mount gelmir or fighting
the fire Giant and every time we meet
him Alexander radiates an infectious
jollyness he's constantly laughing and
chuckling even when he almost dies oh
That's mighty Wallop of yours almost
spelled the end of me
[Laughter]
he is always looking on the bright side
of things in a way that doesn't ignore
or minimize The Strife or trials but
takes it head-on and integrates it into
something brighter we see this
integration on strong display at the
radon Festival heading towards it on the
blighted road Eastward we see Alexander
overflowing with excitement he talks
about the expected Festival of Rodan
where he hopes to learn more about the
ways of War he says I'd heard Whispers
of such festivities before doesn't the
Notions set your breast a flutter
once again we see his joyous attitude
towards combat and this positive
disposition towards conflict is a
central feature of Elden ring and his
forebears in discussing the role of
conflict in the game Miyazaki said in an
interview that in our game specifically
hardship is what gives meaning to the
experience and that he wants as many
players as possible to experience the
joy that comes from overcoming hardship
I touched on this concept in My
Philosophy video along with another
Point by philosopher Frederick Nietzsche
whose writings have been a powerful
influence both directly and indirectly
on Elden ring as the Iron Fist gets
giddy about growing his skills of
warfare he perfectly encapsulates
something nature wrote about men or jar
men in this case that they are to be
trained for war all else is folly and
War training indeed takes place in the
great battle against radon before the
fight Alexander is nervous but at the
same time bursting with anticipation
I could face a great champion of the
shattering
demigod in the flesh
oh God in truth I quiver at the thought
such is his frightful repute but
the fear simply assures me the ordeal is
worth undertaking he accepts his fear as
part and parcel of an Endeavor which is
worthwhile that it is scary signifies
that it is worth doing we see him find
beauty in darkness once more after the
fight's conclusion at first he is
ashamed saying
ah hello there
um it was a battle marvelously fought
you are well and truly a champion friend
I on the other hand am nothing but a
Croc one hit was all it took to crack me
and for my insides to come spilling out
after that I
hid like a coward and as such
I can hardly stand to face one such as
you
he begins remiss about his poor
performance but as the Paragon of
striving virtue he is Alexander doesn't
stay that way for long instead finds
heart and continues oh
but don't you think I've given up just
yet
as luck would have it there's a
veritable mountain of Warriors bodies
right here
if I can just squeeze this Bunch down
inside me I'll be a mighty warrior again
in no time
and you know the bodies found here are
exceedingly fine who could expect any
less from the very Warriors who fought
in the shattering
greatest of all wars hmm do you asked
you wait and see friend I'll grow even
stronger
just you wait when next we meet
I struck down by the pain of defeat he
takes it as an opportunity to grow
gaining strength through those who had
fallen in the field of battle and of
course he finds time to laugh about it
all too then he continues his journey we
find him stuck again during a brief
moment of nostalgia and mortishness near
his home jarberg we find him tempering
himself in the fires of Mount gilmir a
Mountain of Fire Bake Me In Your Flames
he even joins us atop the highest peak
in the lanes between for an epic fight
against the fire giant above the lofty
clouds the icy Giants peaked doth soar
hear lieth the flame of Ruin whichever
burning roars
after the fire Giant and his guard is
felled we come to crumbling faram Azula
a snapshot out of time and the real
beginning of our Journey's End at the
culmination of this dungeon We Begin The
Boss Gauntlet which continues through to
the game's finale it is also here where
we find the conclusion to Alexander's
questline we are here to fight him for
his journey of combat and championing
could have no other end more true
when we find Alexander he has something
to ask of us in full he says ah I see
you finally made it here yourself
the city hanging in the air is slowly
crumbling
what an incredible place we find
ourselves
but that's a side you're certainly a
force to be reckoned with EH I doubt
there's a single soul who could have
handled that giant other than you it was
practically a god of course I count
myself the great Alexander among the
many
which means I've put one thing to ask of
you would you kindly undertake my ordeal
come and tell me when you're ready
I've been longing to fight a warrior as
accomplished as you
you are ready then I take it
then let us begin
I am the great jar Warrior
and me strength o Warriors Within let us
become one Champion together
Alexander has undertaken his journey
through the lands between her combat for
battle for growth and for the Jolly
times that such a journey brings here at
the End of Time the only thing we can do
to honor and act right by him is to
match that conviction to quote Nietzsche
once again and one's friend one should
have One's best enemy Alexander
recognizes us as one of the mightiest in
the land and that means that we are one
of the best enemies he could have this
fight happens as a testament to our
shared camaraderie friendship and
respect it is an embracement of the
ideals Nietzsche highlights in his works
and Miyazaki has woven into these games
and all of this truly comes to its
Bittersweet yet merry culmination at the
end of the fight once we best Alexander
he departs with these final words
as I suspected
victory
was impossible this vessel was found
lacking my thanks
I knew you were the stuff of Champions
it was a marvelous battle
I implore you
take what I bequeath
from inside me
all vessels are destined to one day
break
but the great Alexander lived as a
warrior to his last
hahaha
Alexander passes on in positive
affirmation he knows that death comes
for us all and he is at peace with that
he accepts his life including its end
content and exuberant with Joy about how
he lived in his last moments he goes
with laughter and just as we couldn't
expect any other end to Alexander's
Journey other than this fight we could
never expect him to pass on in any
manner other than Jolly Merriman he had
to laugh
here he once more extols the game's
virtue in line with miyazaki's hopes
Alexander finds joy in the hardship of
life and conflict and in light of when
Nietzsche pronounced laughter holy
Alexander becomes Divine in his passing
and he even continues to be an advocate
for perseverance after dying when he
goes he drops two items The Shard of
Alexander and Alexander's innards The
Shard is a testament to his strength it
strengthens our skills and notes the
inclusion of radon's power the innards
however are not used by his players
instead they are passed on to jar Baron
a young Warrior jar hopeful who wishes
to follow his uncle Alexander's
Footsteps in becoming a great warrior
the innards note that the jars contain
dregs inherited from those who came
before thus our Warriors passed from jar
to jar carrying dreams of greatness in
jar Baron Alexander and his driving will
live on helping the young Warrior to
grow and giving him a great base of
power to build off of especially
considering it even has a piece of radon
Alexander was a mighty friend and
Warrior he embodied the nietzschean
ideals of self-overcoming and finding
joy in struggle ideas that permeate
Eldon ring in the Lanes between his
journey is one that provided us with
flight and levity throughout our own
struggles in the game his end provided
us with a profound Beauty and acceptance
of life he affirmed to the highest
degree in a way unmatched by many maybe
even most other stories and characters
it is a lesson the game tries to impart
in many ways but Alexander may be the
most personal seeing as how he was and
is our friend and outside of the lands
between IRL we are in our own time of
merriment and maybe we can Elevate this
season by remembering the example
Alexander lived I have no doubt that
Nietzsche would have considered a
character of Alexander's Merit to be fit
for the title ubermensch one who makes
their own way and lives in full
affirmation of life and I think we can
all agree that Alexander is fit to be
called the jolliest of all the NPCs
did the story and lore of Alexander
leave you with any particular feeling if
so let me read about it in the comments
if you enjoyed the video you can
subscribe support me on patreon or join
my Discord thank you all for watching I
wish you a wonderful Christmas holiday
season and changing of years
peace